other statement reads on behalf of  myself rachel and our family we'd like  to say thank you to everyone for all  your get well wishes and your amazing  generosity and we are completely  overwhelmed by it he says a special  thanks to the staff at the liverpool  women's hospital the staff and the  medical team at the a tree hospital and  the merseyside police and they also  thank  counter terrorism policing who have all  been amazing they say  david goes on to say i feel like it's a  miracle that i'm alive and so thankful  that no one else was injured in such an  evil act i now need time to try to come  to terms with what's happened and focus  on my recovery both mentally and  physically so that's a statement from  david perry the taxi driver